j'ai laissé passer son temps à méditer
[Musique]
halloween welcome à la halle aux gt ce
dieu l'inquiétait scrutin que indien ne
déteste pas souvent une bouteille subira
ya tant que
si vous aimez les allées chapeau coup la
mairie
merci bienvenus
bienvenue aux enfants la divine on y va
merci mais c'est quoi elle ça fait
montré aujourd'hui fait un petit écart
et une nouvelle alliance de riz le
granier qui ne donne elle à l'ail
l'oignon
j'ai pas compris ce qu'est la laïcité
c'est à plat épicé ce clip de la réunion
dedans il ya les tomates joignons et de
live on le mange un peu fleuri et le
[Musique]
palais s'est rendu à l'audience a à peu
près 10 et les allées
avec six jeunes la chatte est un peu la
danse un peu accueillant drogué un
caillou à l'autre et comment s'appellent
ces instruments à cordes s'installe et
ça c'est ainsi qu'il a retrouvé la joie
de là
merci pour contrat que chaque penja
c'est votre cas ni de la ville
d'ailleurs quand on a mal on voyait
zemmour enfants rentrent bien
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui le chapeau que marie
données tient le paragraphe commentaires
vraiment oui z'êtes sûr oui merci
[Musique]